depuis quelques jours l'un de mes
chroniqueurs préférés est au coeur d'une
sombre affaire c'est pas moins 10 du nez
ça comme on dit quand on s'attaque à un
membre de tpm p c'est à toute la france
qu'on s'applique pour tout comprendre
regardez chez vous ce qui s'est passé
dans l'émission de jeudi j'ai pris ce
montant a pris feu ce matin 5h10 savait
comment j'ai pris feu parce que j'avais
gardé une piles usagées dans mon
pantalon non mais oui oui et je ne
savais pas qu'il fallait jamais mettre
une piles usagées avec des pièces de
monnaie dans un enjeu c'est ouf parce
que sa combustion
oui je suis allé voir les pompiers tout
ça parce que j'ai dû enlever le pantalon
est douce amère quand il a enlevé son
pantalon pattes avec une fille elle est
folle non mais à l'époque ce soir
[Applaudissements]
vous venez de voir
ça s'est passé jeudi aux alentours
le 19h15 la france était contente le
plateau riez les gens étaient mal
jusqu'à ce sont - rebondissements dans
la journée de vendredi
je suis tranquillement en train de faire
des boulettes voilà mon téléphone vibre
alerte imposture aux graves
deux solutions s'offrent à moi où j'ai
avec les boulettes ou je réponds avec
des boulettes dans la main j'ai répondu
et
on m'a fait part de ce qui s'était passé
regardez ce qui s'est passé quelques
heures avant sur la radio belge une
radio qui s'appelle vivacité oui c'est
pas pour vous restez sur rtl un truc sur
les piles aussi ne les mettait pas en
poche vous savez ce qui peut se passer
sur un média fillon poche
est-ce que ça font pas ça peut prendre
feu un jour j'ai une approche qui a pris
feu ah ouais ouais je vais oser les
piles rectangulaire avec les deux bouts
et ben ça s'est mis en contact avec une
pièce je ne sais pas pourquoi j'avais
une pile dans la poche mais ça s'est mis
en contact avec une pièce
donc ça fait un court circuit un moment
je sens la peau d'un dj chauffe un peu
et qu'est ce qui se passe est en fait la
poche avait commencé à brûler ce serait
bien de la pile quand tout va bien
oui oui tout va bien le seul drame c'est
que la pile ne fonctionnait plus après
ça mais est à éviter
[Applaudissements]
je vous plaît s'il vous plaît ne jugeons
pas les gens à l'emporte-pièce il vous
plaît vous allez passer au détecteur de
mensonges fabien loskov m'étais juste un
petit tabouret non non non mais honda
n'ont pas avant que je suis jamais
exactement le cadre ne condamne pas
avant de jugement alors voilà de suite
détecteur de mensonge puisque giuseppe
l'animateur que j'embrasse est très
sympathique
madiba battu régler ce mystère il est
donc de tirer cette affaire au clair au
sujet du pile slipgate fabien lecoeuvre
vous n'êtes pas ce détecteur de
mensonges vous allez répondre par oui ou
pas devant la france entière
c'est hyper flip
fl fait vous appelle et faire ce que
vous avez une tour dans le ca non c'est
également ses initiales à des vous êtes
invité sur la radio vivacité sais pas
pour vous jeudi dernier le 28 novembre
oui non mais on le savait on sait
[Rires]
remettre les choses dans son contexte
fabien thiémé d'eau polluée palanquée
[Rires]
avez vous entendu l'animateur de radio
belge cyril de taye raconté cette
anecdote au moment où vous étiez dans
les couloirs de la radio
non le détecteur de mensonges c'est moi
face à vous maintenant mais j'insiste
non et avez-vous donc oui ou non piquée
l'anecdote de cet animateur le soir même
pour raconter une histoire de langres à
tous et sachez que je ne vous en voudrez
pas de tendresse qui aura juste une
sanction non de quelques millions de
kenyans non non non
est-ce que vous pouvez nous jurer way
sur la toya jackson un que vous n'avez
pas piqué cette anecdote
oui
en tant oui donc fabien même arrêter
avec ça va bien vous êtes en train de me
dire les yeux dans les yeux que
l'anecdote est arrivé au même moment par
l'opération du saint-esprit
au même moment alors on va reprendre les
dates fabien les heures mais les heures
talo minutes allez-y moi je passe à
l'antenne sur vivacité de
cette de 8h40 à 9 heures d'accord ils
ont raconté juste avant que j'arrive et
sur le plateau et en coulisses votre
anecdote
ils ont raconté une histoire enfin c'est
une histoire semblable qui est pas tout
à fait la même puisque vous je rappelle
que moi la pile était ronde
[Applaudissements]
non en plus sincèrement on a été fait
ailleurs
d'ailleurs la tbf m'a appelé le soir
même puisque le soir même j'étais parti
à nantes
oui ils m'ont appelé et ils ont retiré
immédiatement ce canular qu'ils ont mis
sur l'antenne en s'excusant parce qu'il
était désolé de m'avoir traité de bien
sur deux aux leurres ou de je ne sais
quoi c'est non on appelle ça une
synchronicité dans la vie ah ouais c'est
à dire qu'il ya deux personnes fait
revivre la même histoire la même journée
ah ouais bah un moment précis et et et
on peut croire que l'a empruntée à
l'autre ça s'appelle une synchronicité
pour la paix complète juste comme on
appelle quand quelqu'un se fout de votre
gueule là et moi j'ai des doutes
pourquoi l'animateur belge
moi je n'ai pas entendu sur le plateau
pourquoi lui après ma venue
ouais pourquoi il n'a pas mis cette
histoire le lendemain pour faire un buzz
et blake usa la course est un piège à
buzz est le piège à buzz bien sûr vous
l'accusez donc la coque et oui oui
accuse non mais ils n'ont que des
présomptions cyril tissu des missions
très sympa d'aller bien sûr mais ce ne
sont que sur des présomptions et
sincèrement dans mes sincères à bien je
n'ai jamais entendu ces il ya une pièce
à conviction
c'est le pain le pantalon ouais bah je
suis élu je serai mieux avec je le
regarde et je les gardais bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
une personne s'est posé la question
qu'une autre personne peut avoir vivre
aussi la même chose alors fabien je vais
faire le tour de table
ouais nous loi ce que vous croyez vous
dites oui ou non
mais avant qu'il donne ses explications
gens le croyaient expliquez moi je crois
au km 100 pour le j'ai envie de le
croire
jean-michel pas une seule seconde
qu'elle dit jamais de la vie
c'est méchant berne à la vraie question
que je me pose c'est pourquoi il a été
invité sur tout
[Applaudissements]
je vais tous les faits tous les boules
[Rires]
au fait vous salir si faux que j'ai
envie de le croire
d'accord oui avant l'antenne tu ne l'a
expliqué en détail oui bien sûr je te
crois pas dit je pense que fabien moment
parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas touché le
petit chapeau qui est devant lui comme
s'il était vraiment très mal à l'aise
non pas du tout non non s'il a souvent
touché des chapeaux voir et vous voyez
un caractère trop pourri ça s'est passé
à 8 heures du matin il me la raconte à
20h ce qu ont raison 8h du matin 20
heures coûte et fabien moi je vous dire
la vérité
ouais je me suis fait ma petite idée
enfin et dans un instant je vous dirai
ce qu'il va en advenir
fabien avez vous prévu une valise je
vous lis je suis en mesure de venir
fabien je vous crois vous avez pas le
cas
je vois pas bien le faire